What's up guys?
A couple years ago we built a really cool gun wall for all our prop guns.
But since then, not only has jake gotten a degree in law and a doctorate in engineering,
but we got WAY more guns, so we gotta keep them all somewhere
So he built a brand new gun wall that's even cooler than our last one
Jake: Let's go!
*clap clap*
Sam: Okay, not bad, not bad.
BUT, but, this is what I'm really excited about
They installed lights in here, too. Check this out.
Jake: Oooohhh. Shiny!
Sam: Yeah.
Man, which one's my favorite?
I like this one a lot, this one's cool.
Jake, what about you?
Jake: Ah, I'm always a big fan of the shot- shot- shotguns, man.
Just classic.
Johnny: I'm going with the Glock over here.
Sam & Jake: That's not a Glock.
Johnny: It's not a Glock?
Wren: My favorite gun is probably this gun.
What's your favorite gun?
Cmike: Revolver.
Wren: Classic!
*gun recoil*
Cmike: Woaahhh!
Sam: Some of the are loaded.
Wren: You just leave it. Hahahaha!